Im Zuge der Ausbildung der Militärpiloten, wird für unsere Hubschrauberpiloten auch der Hochgebirgslandelehrgang durchgeführt.
Der Hochgebirgslandelehrgang ist nun auf der einen Seite ein Ausbildungsgang
für unsere angehenden Militärhubschrauberpiloten,
aber auch eine gute Trainingsmöglichkeit für unsere erfahrenen Piloten,
die auf einem Hubschraubersystem wie zb dem Black Hawk,
die AB212, Alouette III und der OH58 eingesetzt werden.
Unsere Flugschüler lernen dabei, Landungen im Hochgebirge sicher durchführen zu können.
Dies bei allen Wetterbedingungen, im Sommer wie im Winter,
bei Tag und bei Nacht und bei allen
möglichen Geländeformen.
Im Hochgebirge haben wir ganz andere Verhältnisse als hier unten im Tal.
Die Windströmungen sind intensiver, aber auch die Luftdichte verändert sich markant
im Vergleich zu unseren 500 Höhenmeter, wo wir jetzt sind.
Währenddessen ich im Tal einen unteren Blatteinstellwinkelwert verwenden muss,
muss ich im Hochgebirge fast doppelt so viel an meinem Leistungshebel ziehen,
und das muss ich regelmäßig trainieren, weil das ein Handwerk ist,
das man nur beherrschen kann, wenn man es regelmäßig macht.
Was ist nun der Nutzen von diesem
Hochgebirgslandelehrgang?
Dieser Hochgebirgslandelehrgang befähigt alle unsere Hubschrauberpiloten
für eine sichere Flugdurchführung im Hochgebirge. Damit kann sichergestellt werden,
dass einerseits militärische Einsätze, zum Beispiel zur Unterstützung von Bodentruppen,
wie zb Gebirgsjägern mit Lufttransport, Luftaufklärung oder
Feuerunterstützung aus der Luft,
unterstützt werden können.
Aber auch andererseits Assistenzeinsätze geleistet werden können, wie zb bei
der Suche nach Vermissten zu unterstützen, oder auch zb bei der Evakuierung von Zivilpersonen
von defekten Skianlagen, wie wir es
in der letzten Woche hatten.